fatality
Southall wins
fatality fatality West wing's
[Music]
fatality best wins
[Applause]
why you thirsty I could use a few pints
fatality Johnny
kids win
cut reset the uppercut take to action
high school hired this guy with the flop
deadly uppercut take 19 Holliday Johnny
Cage wins
calling an air support
fatality
Sammy wins
fatality tussock page wins
fatality tussock age wins
fatality jumps weeds
[Music]
fatality fatality fatality score wins
soft winds
[Music]
fatality Noob Saibot wins
holiday
[Music]
fatality read lips
the mentality really lose
[Music]
fatality
Jackie Greaves wins
Jackie briefs wins fatality sub-zero
wings
fatality
sub-zero wings
[Music]
fatality Taylor wins
fatality cabal lives
fatality the ball win
fatality new time wins
fatality Gaetano wins
[Music]
holiday kilo wins fatality G wins
[Applause]
two wins
fatality State wins
fatality stabbed with
[Music]
holiday Aaron black wins
fatality
Aaron black wins
fatality Denari wounds
holiday the air wings
brutality
Kimiko
[Music]
fatality
kvitko wounds
fatality duis weeks
fatality
give us weeks
[Applause]
fatality collective wins
[Music]
fatality Centurion wins fatality central
wins
[Applause]
[Music]